for a brief moment it looked as though
another star was going to clamber aboard
the hashtag me to bandwagon actress Pam
Dawber starred opposite Robin Williams
in the hit comedy show from the 70s Mork
& Mindy and was interviewed for an
upcoming biography on the comic who died
in 2014 her memories of working with
Williams quotes I was flashed humped
bumped grabbed recalled 66 year old pan
and she added he would sometimes wrestle
her to the ground and lie on top of her
or appear stark naked when they're about
to start filming Rachel none of which am
i seeking to defend and all of which is
way beyond the normal Biff and back of
workplace hijinks however just as I
feared Scotland Yard might try to get
involved knowing their love of pursuing
cases involving celebrities long since
departed
I noticed doors closing comment and I
quote it was so much fun
it was the 70s after all judging events
of decades ago by today's puritanical
paralyzed Moors is absurd let's move on
there's nanu-nanu to see here as you
know I'm a strong supporter I love me
too and time's up and but I do think and
actually Rachel you and I have discussed
it what needs to happen is a much more
nuanced debate and and at the moment
we're conflating slightly inappropriate
behavior with real sexual harassment and
real sexual assault in the same way that
we know that there's a difference
between a shoplifter and an armed robber
and the conversation we have about the
two are completely different so I think
the good thing about what pam has done
is perhaps it will actually open up that
nuance within this conversation and
allow more women to to express
themselves and not feel victimized all
the time because she's saying she wasn't
a victim she's saying that actually that
was the culture at the time and she
found it quite funny we opened the show
with you quite rightly being labeled as
being hysterical Rachel
has there been hysteria here though
again not condoning recent acts but we
go back Jun rightly says has there been
a degree of history and hashtag me to my
my point on me to is that if it's not
we're not going to be likely relieved
and remain constantly at war we've got
to take hash tag men to along with the
me to movement
it cannot be oppositional it's got to be
united yes
but going to your nano nano Morcom
indicates which i think is is hysterical
and also refreshing we've got a
refreshing well in the sense that it's a
women woman do you think to a racial
which is that wrong accepting that you
know male-female relations is a bit can
be a bit of a rough and tumble but
however it was the 70s is the Jimmy
Savile defense and I'm Carolann iovis of
the age where you know we're pretty
robust when it comes to these things and
we absolutely refuse you know to accept
that we are victims and you know you
have to allow things to happen to you um
however if Robin Williams had stripped
off he was a jolly hairy man is also the
Cosby defense in defense of your point
and so we do need to be slightly que no
criminality here with indeed was my next
point actually [ __ ] up Julie so so in
that yes the defense can sometimes fall
apart in Cosby case and in the Jimmy
Savile case it clearly does fall apart
because you can't just say that was a
70s when you're raping children or
drugging women right but actually to
June's point there is it we do have to
differentiate between various types of
assaults I think you're right do we have
to be able to but somebody tried that
didn't they Matt Damon will try to
differentiate and let's go to cases
where we have got you know as much
details we can work with cows strangely
quiet but I sense of all the people
right yes indeed
you're probably the closest to my
thinking on this is because I think I
think she she she pricked the moral
pomposity of some of them a two times
Appa gate
you know I really resent this idea that
women are reduced to a quivering mass of
fear and nerves if a guy brushes DNA
she makes a little joy he grabs your ass
and the idea that we can't most wasn't
conned
oh no I did seriously good you know but
we're not we're not quivering we're not
weak we're not we're not these powerless
and in the face here that you go running
to HR because a guy raises his hand
across your knee that is not abuse and
that's what June was talking about this
is we make the point about power if the
man has power over the women and is you
know in a position of authority yeah
then we have to keep sort of fighting
that right that's what we're talking
about but that what this lady highlights
Pam Dawber is the difference between she
saw the difference between fun and
mischief and flirting and real predatory
behavior and they're French and there's
a massive difference and I'm sorry in in
in the meeting times up situations many
people will refuse to see that it was
refused to admit it's there and that's
and yeah in you know I agree with a lot
of what you said much not the we got
there running to HR because I think
that's what take it yeah and I think
that's what HR is therefore we need we
need you press but isn't the way it's
done the way this this flirting is done
that makes a difference he was a funny
guy yeah
but anyway what I'd love to do is show a
clip of tirana Burke who's the founder
of the me to movement here's what she
has to say sexual violence is deeply
pervasive and it such as everybody
across race class gender and ability and
so
and I think that's a Rachel's point
about men - is where sexual harassment
and sexual assault is concerned it's
usually a small group of men actually
committing the majority of the crimes so
in the case of Harvey Weinstein it was
him in that company doing the majority
of the harassment and I think this is
the problem it's not the majority of men
it's a few men that are actually doing a
lot of harm and so therefore we should
make sure that the conversation is clear
we're not demons right I think it wasn't
he tried to make the nuanced point
you're making about the categorization
of the different crimes he wasn't
shouting on he was like and it's like I
think that's a man needs to be able to
speak make this at this point as well as
a woman we shall only conversation if
that's the reason yes remember she spoke
out against the big joke again and she
says what began is freeing women are up
to speak has today turned into the
opposite we intimidate people into
speaking correctly shout down those who
don't fall into line and those women who
refused to bend are regarded as
complicit and traitors and I'm afraid
that's what's happened in many ways of
the medium so how's the dialogue one
back Jim but I think it's it's important
that women like ourselves who think the
way we do that we stand up and actually
we're the ones that create a space for
men to enter the conversation and I do
think it's evolving I do think it's
don't forget this has just started so
we're at the beginning of this I do
think it's evolving you know majid
without doubt Robin Williams would have
been a complex and challenging character
to work with it like you and Kara Malone
in the workplace does it change forever
the dynamic in the world yeah yeah I
think so and I think that um I think
that in many cases for the better
because of course some of these certain
many cases so in many cases for the
better because some of these excesses
that occurred during the world pace were
criminal and so if we can stop at least
most of those criminal sides of the
transgression tell you shrug with
with people young women were being
illegally prayed I'm not talking about
I'm talking about how the rules that are
now in place wouldn't we'll make it
almost impossible for any workplace
banter men and women have to be able to
interact in the workplace you know we
think about it many people's
relationships are formed in the world
how don't you think we do need rules we
do we do we do but to know what the
bound we do but this Catherine Deneuve's
just said it's it's turned into a movie
where people have to speak correctly and
and they have to be careful about every
word they say every gesture they make
every touch they make no kind of guy can
you could you in an office now touch
Mormons oh maybe it's gonna take that to
get to concept
history normally says it just builds on
itself just because they're you know why
cuz we if you put these rules down that
are so impossible to adhere to and I so
unhuman you know because human beings
whether with a man or a woman are whole
I will do this right now you see me
around my my guy friends my arms around
them all the time yeah well they call
what they call it horseplay yeah still
burn on a single man thinking